i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right y'all let me just say
congratulations i was there on monday
night at the premiere and y'all like
brought it from the jump i was like this
is like sit down go to the theater and
kick butt and so samia i have to talk to
you at the premiere on monday it's sort
of like i loved your tweet like you know
you're shouting out like hey marvel can
we make this happen and then like on
monday it it sort of does but
how was that journey with kevin feige
because i know you found out like right
before comic con yeah you got the role
so talk about it i mean that whole
narrative kind of encapsulates the whole
how it started how it's going yeah like
there's no
crazier
kind of two things that you can put next
to each other but yeah no i i
remember auditioning for the part in uh
june of 2019 and of course i tweeted
marvel six months prior
just kind of like i didn't think that i
was going to get the role like i just
you know it's like do you want to win
the lottery they're like sure yeah it'd
be nice yeah like a million dollars why
not
but uh when i actually got the chance to
audition i mean it was i was obviously
very nervous because i knew how you know
not only was a huge fan of comic books
but i knew you know just what you know a
property like this meant for the for the
culture
and um yeah i was i got the call from
kevin because you know he likes to be
the one to break the news and who knows
how many lives he's just totally changed
by doing that but uh he called me on a
tuesday uh evening i was in my underwear
wearing shrimp crackers i don't know why
i looked at you as i was saying that i
was you know wearing shrimp crackers
wearing shrimp crackers and eating
underwear what do you like
and i got a call uh from burbank
california and i'm like oh my god you
know it's like unknown number it's very
mysterious so i kind of knew
and uh yeah so kevin was like hi you
know it's it's kevin feige from marvel
studios i'm here to offer you the roll
of chanchi and you're gonna go to san
diego in four days and uh go out in
front of you know 8 000 screaming fans
at comic-con and and you're just gonna
say hi
and also you can't tell anyone he was
like very important like don't tell
anyone don't tell your parents don't
tell anyone in your life to tell your
friends and i was like sure no i won't
let you down like i'm gonna just tight
lip absolutely and then he hung up and
then i immediately called my best friend
because i was just gonna say like you
can't keep somebody like that and then
at least i can't
yeah i would never be in a marvel movie
they would kick me out after
i'm so glad that some of you mentioned
this because there's been this great
sort of resurgence i would say an asian
representation on screen and girl you've
been a part of a lot of them
between crazy rich asians to farewell it
was so great seeing john at the premiere
as well but i have to feel like every
cast brings something different and
every film brings something different
what is it about this particular
property because i feel like when you
get into the superhero realm and even
with rya like with the animation this
just brings something else to it so what
do you feel that is i mean i don't think
we've seen i've seen anything quite like
this and and yeah i've been a part of
some like really amazing
uh i've had the honor of being a part of
them crazy rich asians um being the
first and i and i what i've noticed
throughout the years is that
representation is ever evolving and
within it is very diverse um their
representation can spill into any kind
of genre which is like this this
specific movie i think has will have a
lasting impression on
you know what it means to be asian
american today you know um to have a
superhero that that has that has cmu's
face is like very important and yeah
it's ever evolving yeah and even from
the little touches that like dustin did
from like kung fu hustle and warriors on
the wall to like the incredible fight
sequences and florian i'm bringing it to
you sir uh you and simu have this this
the bus
that bus boy that that whole sequence i
think is just crazy and i think i just
have to ask you what was it like
preparing for that and i'll come back to
you smear like sure that's got to be
just nuts it was so much fun to watch
but i imagine it was painful to prepare
i mean seems like that are always tough
to shoot but uh i think to me and to
simul it comes very naturally because
also sigma has a martial arts background
i'm coming from boxing
and we try to to create something that
people have never seen before
and we both had the same mindset
and i think you can see that on screen i
think we delivered big time
also i have to admit like we spent like
three weeks in that bus and that bus is
so uh tight and i'm a big guy it was not
easy for me to move i mean moves like a
ninja but
it was not easy for me to move in that
bus but we made it happen
every time i'm watching it
that uh specific scene i'm very proud of
it and i i think siemens as well
yeah we
hit like our head
shoulders shins knees we pretty much
scraped on every possible just like
square inch of that bus that stuck out
because you know you think every seat
every handrail like that all just like
lessened the amount of space that we had
to actually move around and like florian
mentioned he's pretty like he's he's
swole dude his dude is i follow him on
instagram i know yeah yeah yeah
i
need to put on a shirt once in a while
but i mean
i mean maybe not because he's old
and you know when he's like he literally
standing up tall like how far was your
head
from the top of the bus i feel like it
was like you were clearing it by like
this much i mean since we always were
jumping and moving i hit it a couple of
times there was no space at all
it really was i mean it wasn't easy and
not not only that he's dealing with like
an entire green screen um
like weapon yeah uh
yeah i loved it and i'm i'm appreciating
you aquafina up at the front being like
y'all have fun i'm gonna be up here
[Laughter]
your character i do have to say
she really i think personifies what's
great about the mcu which is that and i
don't want to spoil anything there's so
many stories we can explore and like i
feel like there's with her i'm just like
i just want to know about what she was
doing like for parts that were not part
of like shanghai like what was she have
going on and would you want to see that
though maybe in a disney plus expanded
universe like what would you like to see
your character do maybe on the small
screen if they expanded her story i
don't know i just i'm so new to this and
you're like yeah i'm really excited for
whatever in front of it like next for
her
i'll tell you what you want yeah you
want a disney a ride at disneyland yes
let's go yeah i would love a ride yes
yes the shelling right what would it be
what what would it be the shelling right
i feel like you you love this for her
mother
i'm just grateful to be here yeah you
want to ride you want to ride you've had
a ride already because i will say the
person that you spend a lot of the time
with and i think all of y'all too was
was ronnie and i just feel like any time
he's around it was probably hysterical
can you talk about working with him
because how did you keep a straight face
because the minute he came on screen i
was just like all right
we're gonna giggle
yeah i just i love working with him
because he's so funny and i just i just
love watching
all of them roasting each other
constantly like on set and and just
you know yeah and he he's great i love
the uh announcement he he made for my
character yes and
and he he's very he he he came to me and
every time he asked me so tell me how to
pronounce your character's name correct
because i want to make it like correct
and clear i love it i love that
attention to details yes yes um i also
the what's great about this is this
supporting cast on top of you guys
there's just so many incredible names
and faces someone we can't mention but
i'm just saying the cast is so great
with this one but we can't go anywhere
without talking about tony and just like
the i guess the legacy he brings with
that so
i'll just start with maybe you aquafina
and have everybody talk about working
with sing tony's praises yeah because i
mean he's done it all he's very legend i
mean if you're a fan of tony long it's
like working with him is is just like a
really incredible treat because and and
if you don't if you didn't know who tony
lang was it's still a treat because
you're just like god he's such a
powerful actor like where have i seen
him from and
um this role i think specifically like
there's certain parts of it where it's
like if this if it wasn't tony it would
be a completely different
performance and um he's such a powerful
actor like like just to the to the to
the core yeah coming to y'all but i want
to ask florian because you i mean like
if you told me to do anything i'd be
like yes sir but like that's like mostly
what your character was was just like
whatever uh he had to tell you to do and
so i would just be like geeking out
being like okay i gotta keep straight
face but that's totally loose
yeah well totally like aquafina said
tony is the legend and
you know i remember that one dinner
scene um when he was giving his speech
and his son just came back to the
compound
i always remember you know watching him
i i was totally mesmerized by the way
he was doing that scene and how he was
delivering the lines and that already
shows you how much of a legend he is and
by the way
he's a legend on the glass as well he's
a very good drinker i'm telling you that
he's a good drinker and i appreciate my
boss
drinking with me so shout out to toby
especially if he was going shot to shop
for you just the like chemistry of that
like you're a bigger dude you can drink
a little bit more and get over on him i
appreciate that
right
trust me on that i like that i'm so
happy that he went there it's so great
uh and then for you guys like it's
different i would imagine the the
paternal aspect and how much he wanted
to talk about you know how he relates to
your character his character playing the
dab because i feel like whenever
somebody is playing your dad on screen
it just adds another level and then
having it be somebody who you would of
course be like hey what was it like
shooting this and really want to talk to
him about you know the other projects
that he did so sami i'll start with you
and then if you guys can follow up yeah
what's it like having that as your dad i
mean it's pretty yeah you talk about
casting a large shadow i mean i had been
such a massive fan of tony first of all
from infernal affairs which was probably
the first project that i saw him in and
then just totally you know like florian
said just absolutely mesmerizing
performer and i watched him and he was
phenomenal in hiro one of my favorite
movies and his character and and what he
you know
what he does in that movie there's this
one particular scene that's so beautiful
that takes place in the water um he's
just so incredibly expressive he's able
to say so much while sometimes not ever
opening his mouth you know and uh so
yeah that's kind of what what i knew i
was i was gonna kind of be going up
against when i was when i want to when i
would be shooting the movie um
and then you know you have you form all
these kind of assumptions and
expectations in your mind over what
somebody of that stature would be like
you know and oftentimes people are
inaccessible or they're far away they're
very you know but but tony you know from
day one just greeted all of us with such
a warm smile and like a very such a
humble and and you know paternal kind of
demeanor really did feel like he was
looking out for us and he was just so
gentle and kind um so we we got into
that dynamic pretty pretty easily and uh
what can i say other than he's he's the
goat
yeah he's the goat and then i would
imagine you know this is very early on
in your career like what when did you
know he was going to be a part of it and
did you have like that like freak out
moment
tony long yes i mean i i feel very lucky
because he never played anyone's dad on
screen right so we are
yeah we are his very first like yes
and so we really
for me i didn't really hat to anything i
just be there and
i just follow him just like he just drew
is everything
it's just amazing and i i could watch
his performance
under a microscope every details and
such small things he does just make huge
impact for the character
and
i mean his work ethic is amazing yeah
he's yeah he never went back to his
trailer he never asked for anything and
he just
quiet set and watch and always prepared
always ready yeah always ready
yeah i learned so much it's a testament
because when you see what he does on
screen and i'm not just talking about
the action stuff there's some really
emotional things that happen in this and
he's just obviously the perfect person
to pull all of that off and i love that
a lot of folks are gonna get introduced
to him from this film because you know
maybe they don't know about him and he
can join this sort of like mcu family
but
your character runs an underground
fighting ring and i know that i would
definitely pick anything that tony was
going to do to like go up against
another mcu character i don't care if
it's thor i just want to see that but
i'm going to ask all of you really
quickly if there's anyone from the mcu
you'd want to see like go head to head
in like that underground fighting ring
because we get to see wong fight some
pretty incredible stuff when he gets
introduced but um aquafina i'll start
with you who would you want to see go
toe-to-toe in like an underground fight
from the mcu characters um
uh i guess
i would i guess monger
and groot
[Music]
let's go i actually really like that i
really like it but it would be cool if
like it was like if then you you know
like it was like it wasn't you know you
didn't kill each other yeah but i mean i
i wouldn't know if if he talked about me
in the fight because he only said
so
you would need rocket on the side during
like the announcement right like to
translate rocky rocket would have to be
outside he'd have to be outside
we're me and ryan
yeah yeah right he couldn't be inside
yeah for sure
what about you
um i want to see i want to see kept oh
god i'm blanking on the right oh yeah i
want to see red guardian versus captain
america just because he keeps talking
about it yeah you know i i you know i
watched black widow it was a great movie
and and you know he's talking about
facing off against captain america and
you're like well there's no way like on
the timeline there's no way you could
have it's not physically possible like
we know you're lying they would they
would get the bigger stage though yeah
yeah i mean he could try and fight sam
wilson's captain america now but i
wouldn't put that bet out there either
for red guardian either like it's not
it's not gonna work is there room in the
calendar for for all these fights that
we're planning on i want to make it
happen
monger what about you who do you want us
to go toe-to-toe i would love to see
ant-man which is my favorite hero
versus hulk
the biggest and the smallest
i like that all right florian you've
been in a lot of rings so i saved you
for last on this i figure you've got a
few and you can't say razer fist i know
he could beat everybody like but you
can't say razorfest
well my favorite matchup would be
definitely the hulk
against
do shanghai guys remember the first
adventure when hulk picked up loki and
was smashing him
[Laughter]
i want to see shang chi
doing that to her
that's my pick
and i think the master of kung fu can
totally pull that off my man
yeah oh i love it those rings i could
see it all right well i as the internet
starts to write all of that like fight
fan fiction i'm gonna leave you guys
with a lighter one um some of y'all
have action figures have you gotten to
play with yourself yet like you've
gotten to play with your figure i have
your funko pop
play with myself every day oh yeah okay
i play with myself thank you
changeable hands my fully articulated
joints there's so much to play with i'll
do all these different poses do you have
like a toy shrine somewhere or is it
like like
do you like open up your bedroom and or
like are do you put them away in like
shelves i am the i mean look you you
haven't do you don't play with your
action figure i haven't opened it oh man
no because i feel like that'll diminish
the value for my for
grandchildren like i don't want to play
who
my
with this
like it's like we play with virtual
reality sources because it'll be like
the year i don't know
but uh no i keep mine in the box okay
yeah i play with i i got my uh action
figure from cemu it was a present from
him
how are you guys playing with these
dolls
oh yeah i haven't touched any one of
them
oh i was never in the box
my mom tried to tell me that about my
barbies too and i was like nah i like to
play with them
barbies no barbara was the kid the ones
in the box because she was that woman i
don't know
florian last one for you uh have you had
some time with uh razor fists uh or
gifted it sounds like gifting it's a
good idea too
actually my friends are huge marvel fans
and they're
really into comic books and everything
that is surrounded with comic books and
they bought it for me
and then i just gifted it to my dad and
probably you you know yeah
relationship to my dad like my dad is my
best friend and
you know obviously i gifted it to him
and
it's just it makes me happy to see you
know that spark in his eyes when you
know his stuff
gets stuff like that and
delivers something
also i'm proud that now my action figure
is just
next to the tv
at my parents home so that makes me
you can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
[Applause]
uh